la team Farrugia venu en nombre sur ce
plateau du 7 8 Boxing Club d'Élancourt
50 ans en Yvelines bien sûr et pour
parler d'un prochain combat de boxe qui
va se dérouler samedi du côté de
Mulhouse lors de la Fight Night 1 3
combats professionnels au programme 15
combats amateurs et sur le ring
notamment il y aura Kelvin Magic de la
team farouja bonsoir alors vous allez
combattre Anthony feverin dans la
catégorie à poids coque on aura
l'occasion d'en parler dans un instant
juste préciser qu'autour du plateau il y
a le coach Tanguy à faroja bonsoir
Tanguy en face de vous il y a votre
adjoint Philippe Legrand bonsoir et
également Ilan Ilham je dis oui pardon
ok vous êtes cutman ou plutôt même on va
dire cut woman qui a un rôle très
important dans la box juste pas été
spectateur qui ne connaissent pas ce
rôle que Man cut woman qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est essentiellement les bandages
des mains du boxeur soigner le boxeur et
soulager le coach physiquement car le
coach est très pris mentalement et
physiquement voilà
et donc il y aura un rôle primordial
pour le combat de Kelvin qui sera donc
samedi tout à fait bah mon rôle c'est
que qui ne se blesse pas qui termine son
combat
ton gif parce que c'est important de
dire que derrière un boxeur qui va
combattre seul sur le ring il y a toute
une team il y a toute une équipe voilà
c'est une alors comme je dis j'aime bien
dire c'est une histoire de famille voilà
Philippe Legrand c'était le premier
boxeur amateur de mon père voilà et bah
on travaille ensemble et puis l'équipe
s'agrandit avec Ilan et voilà et
bien sûr le boxeur qui est là qui
qui impose ces conditions maintenant
et qui commence à vouloir voilà qui
commence à apprendre ce premier défi
parce que là c'est un vrai défi et on
est là pour on est là on va le relever
alors ce sera le deuxième combat
professionnelle de votre carrière Kelvin
il y avait eu un premier combat en
décembre contre Lite cuisinier c'est ça
vous aviez perdu sur décision des
exactement alors ça reste un petit peu
de frustration il me semble derrière
j'ai pas envie que ça ressemble à une
excuse mais j'estime que je perdais pas
le combat et je suis pas le seul à le
dire des il a mis d'accord avec moi mon
coach aussi mais c'est facile parce que
c'est mon équipe tout le monde a caisse
plateau mais des des spectateurs qui
étaient là qui sont belges et du coup
pas du tout de mon côté m'ont dit que
que je perdais pas le combat donc la
frustration vient de là oui boxer belge
et c'était en territoire belge
exactement et comme je disais j'ai pas
envie que ça je veux pas que ça
ressemble à une à une excuse donc ça
reste une défaite je le prends comme ça
mais j'estime qu'elle est pas totalement
justifiée et là il y a quelques jours de
ce deuxième combat contre Anthony febra
vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit alors
là j'ai pas envie de laisser la son la
chance l'opportunité au juge de Me de me
voler ma victoire donc là je suis dans
un état d'esprit où je dois vraiment
faire la différence
si je peux aller au si je peux mettre un
adversaire chaos je le ferai excusez-moi
ou et en tout cas je donnerai tout pour
pour pas laisser l'opportunité au juge
de me voler mon combat si je dois le
remporter et je ferai tout pour le
remporter qui est-il Anthony Favre c'est
un beau challenge qui s'offre à quel
niveau challenge l'équipe de France
c'était il fait partie de les sélections
olympiques même s'il est pas numéro 1 il
fait quand même il était champion de
France en 2019-2020 c'est un voilà c'est
un beau c'est un beau petit bébé
voilà donc moi je pense qu'il a tout de
toute façon Calvin il a toutes ses
chances il est vraiment bon je reviens
sur son combat qu'il a fait en décembre
et la boxer un poids léger voilà que
Kelvin c'est un poids coach donc on est
monté super coq plume super pub léger
parce qu'il fallait qu'il ait un combat
minimum pour euh pour boxer en France
parce que c'est un règlement parce qu'il
a pas une licence française et il a
battu le il a faim il a battu on l'a on
l'a donné perdant devant le champion de
Belgique là on rencontre le champion de
France
voilà moi je pense qu'il a tous ces
chances oui il est prêt à Philippe
quelles sont ses forces
pas là on serait pas là si on j'en
auraient pas parlé déjà si je croyais
pas en Kelvin je pense qu'il a les armes
pour passer même au dessus de de
cet homme là et c'est bon après il
faudrait qu'on ait qu'on aille pas trop
chez l'adversaire qu'on aille un peu
chez nous aussi voilà mais il a toutes
ses chances d'être voilà de faire
l'international c'est ça pendant le lien
de la box professionnel allez combattre
à l'extérieur ça force forcément c'est
un désavantage disons que là on est dans
l'Est
on a une licence étrangère on est chez
eux on part avec des points de retard
vous croyez en vos champs j'imagine
quand même Calvin on croit en vous en
tout plateau j'ai vu ça j'ai vu ça et je
les remercie oui si je pense que j'avais
pas mes chances bah déjà Tanguy n'aurait
pas accepté le combat et puis je serai
pas là aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
croire en soi pour être pour être un
boxeur pour être un combattant pour être
un sportif dans un milieu compétitif je
pense qu'il faut croire en soi et moi je
crois je crois en moi je travaille pour
j'ai une bonne équipe
je fais ce que j'ai à faire quand je
fais à la salle je me donne les moyens
donc normalement il y a pas de raison
bien sûr je crois en moi et comment vous
vous préparez alors comment je me
prépare bah j'ai ma partie technique qui
est ici avec avec Philippe et on fait
des leçons ou pas d'ours tout ça c'est
chapeauter par par Tanguy qui s'occupe
de mon de ma partie physique qui
s'occupe de la tactique aussi qui
s'occupe aussi de mon mental et j'ai il
aime ici qui s'occupe de bons bien-être
donc de mes mains aussi de mon mental
parce qu'elle fait partie de mon équipe
et comme Tanguy l'a dit c'est une
histoire de famille et j'ai aussi des
sparrings parten avec qui je suis devenu
entre guillemets amis qui m'aide
beaucoup j'ai mes partenaire à la salle
aussi donc voilà un petit peu comment je
me prépare j'ai une partie physique j'ai
une partie physique quand je m'entraîne
le matin ou à midi et j'ai la partie
technique et la partie tactique le soir
à la salle on en revient ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure au début sans équipe
autour de vous pas de combat finalement
sans équipe pas de combat sans équipe
pas de boxeur même si
la lumière est sur moi pendant le combat
sans eux je serai pas là très clairement
sans eux je serai pas là son jeu sans
eux je ne serai pas ce que je suis
aujourd'hui en tant que boxeur en tant
que sportif
j'aurais pas mes capacités je pense
parce que on a tous des capacités de
base mais ils sont peaufinés par ces
gens-là
même mentalement on pense tous qu'on est
on pense tous pardon qu'on a une
certaine limite quand on s'entraîne mais
sans ces gens là pour me pousser bah je
je m'améliorerais pas donc non sans eux
je suis pas là en fait tout simplement
ils sont sans équipe il y a pas de
boxeur on va vous poser à qui on est
dans un instant mais les objectifs pour
qu'elles viennent pour vous
on m'appelle beaucoup en ce moment pour
pour Calvin on va moi je dis déjà on
laisse passer ce qu'on va là et après on
en discute
voilà moi j'aimerais que faudrait que
trouver des sponsors j'aimerais que dans
3 4 c'est un combat on aille sur un
titre pas plus loin parce que je pense
qu'il a les capacités de passer au
dessus aujourd'hui il aime Philippe
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ah oui on
travaille pour ça et puis c'est voilà et
moi je dis c'est un technicien c'est un
bon
il est sérieux il y va et au charbon
donc
futur champion pour moi et donc du coup
Kevin vos objectifs quels sont-ils alors
moi j'aime pas être présomptueux mais
effectivement j'ai
j'ai envie de j'ai envie d'avoir un
titre j'ai envie qu'on puisse m'appeler
un champion
mais je préfère me concentrer sur chaque
étape de mon parcours donc là j'ai envie
de dire mon objectif c'est de remporter
ce combat là et
ensuite une fois que c'est fait
l'objectif ça sera de remporter le
prochain jusqu'à un titre maintenant si
on me demande effectivement mais mes
objectifs à plus long terme oui j'ai
envie qu'on puisse m'appeler un champion
en tout cas on va suivre la suite avec
attention vous souhaite bonne chance
pour ce combat qui a lieu donc samedi du
côté de Mulhouse face à Anthony febra
lors d'une soirée entièrement dédiée à
la box il y aura trois combats
professionnels de combat de la team
farouja c'est ça qui sera le l'autre
boxeur
faut gagner chez eux et on va on va
faire ce qu'il faut on sera bien sûr
d'ailleurs la team fort au diable merci
à toutes et tous d'être venu en PLA